大家好，欢迎来到今天的花风部长湾，我是17岁。
我是小凯，我们今天节目录制时间是在8月31号的上午10点钟。
然后前不久，我刚刚收到一个听友的私信，
跟我们说节目能不能多聊一些娱乐八卦，有这个要求。
对，然后当时我在想说，哪有那么多娱乐八卦，结果没想到。
这一周好忙啊，这一周的娱乐大卦真的特别的多。
就到现在我们录制这一天，这个事都还在不断的发酵。
而且这一周他是先出了包贝尔的那个疑似出轨事件，
对吧，然后大家本来就在吃瓜，
结果突然又出了孙宇辰与锦天三千万财理的这个事情。
那今天这两件事情我们都会给大家来梳理一下。
OK，这是关于娱乐圈的新闻，
接下来还有恒阳老人排管离世的事件。
对，这个讨论度也非常的高，
因为事件好像一直不停的在有很多的一些变化。
就事情很简单，但是它的后续很多。
对，就不知道为啥就是一直一直不停的在有一些这种讨论。
好，另外还有关于奥运冠军非人流翔的安置事件最近也上了热搜。
最后就是跟年轻人息息相关的，
在医院银行网点、地铁站、音乐节、多元场所都开设了婚姻登记点。
你们真的买账吗？
但是在节目正式开始之前，
我们首先还是必须要说到一个非常悲痛的消息，
就是在8月26号的10点30分，
尼泊尔境内的错间河上有发生了高位冰崩。
它引发的是冰崩、碎泻流、泥石流的炼式灾害，
猛烈的冲向了中国机轮口岸，
造成了重大的人员伤亡和失联。
灾害的源头是位于尼泊尔境内海拔约5200米的冰川区。
冰崩体凭借着超过3000米的垂直落差高速下泻，
以平均速度50米每秒，
也就是180公里每小时的速度，
大概仅仅7分钟就冲底到了口岸。
泥石流抵达口岸的时候，水浪一度超过了15米，
也就是五层楼高。
根据灾后的影像我们也是可以看到，
基本上那一片的建筑痕迹都是看不到了。
目前的伤亡统计数据还在不断的更新当中，
救援工作也正在开展。
介绍大家可能在这段时间频频能够接受到的一些消息，
也是希望各位都注意安全，
也希望都能够有更多的伤人者生还。
好，我们接下来就来说一下关于孙宇辰和锦田三千万彩礼的事件，
然后我们今天所有的这些信息是综合来源，
像凤凰网娱乐、新浪娱乐、腾讯新闻、
搜狐娱乐、网易、百度百科，
然后包括一些传统媒体，
像天津广播、杨子晚报等等媒体的公开报道。
然后另外我们要特别说明的是，
我们今天所有说到的这个事情关于这件事情，
它仍然是处于司法的早期阶段，
所以有大量的情节都是孙宇辰单方面的陈述，
没有经过证实的。
我们今天主要的目的是帮大家把这件事情的来龙去脉梳理一下，
因为很多朋友都会说这个事情看上去好复杂，
不知道到底发生了什么，或者两个人到底什么样的背景。
那今天我们会跟大家把这些东西都交代清楚，
以方便大家在后续了解到一些新闻内容的时候知道发生了什么，
能够比较看得懂。
但这个所有的脉络都是截止到现在，
因为这个事情还在不断的延展过程当中。
好，我们首先说一下这件事情当中，
当事人的背景，
其实并不是所有人对于景田都那么熟悉，
虽然大家都可能或多或少看过他的一些作品，
是的,
所以我们现在介绍一下景田，
他是1988年出生在西安的，
他的父亲是姓景，母亲姓田，
所以他的名字叫景田，
只不过说父母把田姓的这个田换成了协音的田，
就是他现在名字这个田，
甜蜜的田，
对，甜蜜的田，
然后他12岁考上了北京舞蹈学院副中，
父母都是在西安工作没有办法陪读，
他是独自的拎着行李北上去读书的，
所以也成为了当时年龄最小的北漂之一，
很多人会觉得说他的资源非常好，
是不是家里的背景很强，
但其实根据现在的媒体公开的一些情况来看，
他家是没有矿，没有人脉，也没有背景的，
是,
那他的演艺生涯的资源却是好到出奇，
我们来盘点一下，
你像在2011年在电影《战国》当中，
跟孙红磊、金喜善、吴振宇合作，
而且这些演员全部给他做配，
他是主角，
这些演员都是配角，
然后媒体问孙红磊为什么会接这部戏，
然后孙红磊的回答说是他们给的太多了，
这是当时的这个新闻报道，
然后警察故事2013里面他和成龙是扮演妇女的角色，
也因此他的这个背景人脉的传闻是多年不断，
但是这些都是没有被证实过的，
2021年他凭借着电视剧司腾当中女王级的角色翻红，
也是稳住了他的路人员，
当然还有一个我觉得值得一提的就是长城，
对吧,
因为最近我看了那个奥德塞、马克达蒙，
当时为了接长城这部戏，
痛施海边的曼扯斯特，
对,
而且这部电影也是一直成为了他后面演艺生涯当中很多的一个一个笑料，
是马克达蒙的，
直到最近他的奥德塞相远很多朋友也看了，
在长城当中景田也是女主，
对,
所以资源真的是非常非常的好，
2022年5月份的时候他因为违法的广告代言，
被广州市市场监管部门是伐莫合计722.12万元，
并且当时是被处以三年的广告代言禁令，
2025年9月份也就是去年9月禁令才到期，
但是他的这个商务就是一直没有恢复，
是,
对,
他在之前其实代言的这个产品也是挺多的，
有十几个中高端的代言，
但是后面禁令期当中因为有三年的时间嘛，
几乎清零了，
而且现在基本上我去特别查了一下，
他手上真正正儿八经的代言是没有的，
他有一些品牌可能是什么合作大使啊等等，
类似于这样的一个身份，
对,
基本上他的长期商务是归零了，
然后就到了今年的1月份，
当时就有报出来说，
他名下的有一套在上海的460平米的江景豪宅，
是挂牌出售，
挂的价格是1.55亿，
然后这个房子当时他2020年的时候是1.38亿全款购入的，
到了今年的5月份这个房子的价格又降到了1.35亿，
就是比他当时买的时候还便宜，
是的,
而且中介也标注了极售，
所以当时这个其实引发了一小波的语情，
我不知道你还记不记得，
就当时就说景田为什么会缺钱，
就是女明星都受豪宅等等这样子的，
还很着急，
是,
然后在关于他的情感方面，
也是根据公开的资料，
首先第一个就是，
很多人应该还记得他早年和影视投资人陆征，
是有恋情传出来的，
但是这个恋情一直都是在网络当中流传，
从来没有任何的官方证实，
直到2017年底他和张济柯传出了匪文，
就是在2018年3月28号张济柯又晒出了他们在海边牵手照来做一个官宣，
然后紧接着景田就转发确认，
所以当时的这个恋情是轰动了全网，
但是到了2019年6月9号，
双方就发文体面分手，
直到2023年3月份，
当时张济柯就爆发了这个赌债风波嘛，
对吧,
然后当时还有网传说他把和景田的私密影像交给了债主抵债，
这个当时好像很多人也在吃瓜，
对,
但也是传文啊，
所以景田他其实也承受了非常大的舆论压力，
然后当时也有报警维权，
但是全程也没有公开的发声指责，
是的,
不过这个事情对他的事业我觉得还是有很大的影响的，
这是关于景田的一些基础信息，
接下来我们看一下孙宇辰1990年出生高中的我考成绩的一般，
就是靠吃透了新概念作文大赛的逻辑，
拿下了第九届的第一灯奖，
也就是07年的时候，
他也是凭此获得了北大自主招生的降分，
最后是以650分考入北大，
先去了中文系，
后面又转到了历史系，
并且也做到了年纪总分第一名，
在北大的求学过程之后，
就赴美国宾西法尼亚大学读硕式，
留美期间用学费来投资特斯拉股票和比特币，
赚老了自己人生的第一桶金，
放弃博士的机会之后又加入到了Repolabs，
任大中华区的首席代表，
也是成为了国内最早一批的区块链从业者，
在之后他通过发币，
加上买交易所等等操作，
身家达到了85亿美元。
因为其实大家都知道孙宇辰他是一个在币圈混的人，
很多朋友可能就是在想币圈是什么，
其实就是虚拟货币嘛，
对不对，
然后他刚刚你提到了一个是发币，
加上买交易所，
他啥意思呢，
就是选第一个发币，
他在2017年自己创办了一个叫波场的虚拟货币项目，
就是他自己发行了一种虚拟货币叫TRX，
就是自己印钱，
你可以这么理解，
然后同时他又买交易所，
因为虚拟货币他需要在一个平台上去进行买卖，
就类似于股票要在政权交易所进行交易嘛，
然后他在2022年前后呢，
花了大概10亿美元把火币买了下来，
自己当老板，
所以他自己发的币在自己的平台上交易，
理论上呢，
他又可以控制这个供给，
供给端，
要就要发多少，
然后又可以控制交易端，
这是为什么缺内人给他起了一个外号，
包括现在很多人大家都在这个网上可以看到，
他有个外号叫孙哥，
哥就是割韭菜的哥，
就是他自己又制定规则自己又去玩，
所以很多的散户其实很难搞赢他，
包括他根据他炒币这一块有很多的一些黑料，
这个大家有兴趣可以自己去看一下。
所以他是非常会营销的，
也非常善于炒作自己，
2019年的5月份以456.79万美元拍下了。
巴菲特20周年慈善午餐创了纪录，
零餐前是以突发盛节时取消了，
最后全网华然公开道歉承认过度营销热中于炒作。
我觉得他真的很厉害，
因为你想想巴菲特的午餐其实很多年了，
大家作为想去炒作自己都会去拍一个巴菲特的午餐，
但是只有他拍下来他不去，
他还找一个理由缺席，
反而就是会创造这种反差舆论，
对舆论很厉害，
并且是搞自己还不是搞别人，
真的很厉害。
根据华尔街日报的评估这场盛节时的戏码为波场。
带来超过2.5亿美元的一个品牌公关价值，
就相当于是让大家其实注意到他，
就是我们前面说到他那个波场就是。
关注的那个平台吗？
是的,
2024年以620万美元拍下了卡特兰的交代香蕉艺术品。
喜剧演员并且是当中把它吃掉，
登上了全球头条，
2025年8月花了2800万美元购买蓝色起源亚轨道太空飞行席位，
上了太空，
就很会炒作自己，
并且都是大事。
然后就到了现在我们平时在热搜上了解到的具体的这个事情，
我们来跟大家一起梳理一下事件的脉络，
第一阶段就是匿名爆料与否认，
2026年4月份就有知情人士爆料，
称以小清新出道的接性女星以代孕生产为名向富豪男友所要上亿钱款，
4月份其实就有一个铺垫，
到5月份这个爆料就升级了，
曝光了一份带有田井签名的海外代孕机构英文协议，
并且以及是大约3000万元的一个转账细节，
就称其为营养费和辛苦费。
称这个男友支付代孕机构首期大约是10万美元，
安排私人飞机赴美，包下洛杉矶高档酒店整层供取诺。
到了5月22号，
景天工作室就发布了一个盖章的严正声明，
圈盘否认了带孕，
巨额资金的纠纷等相关的传闻，
定性为恶意造谣，
已经委托了律师取证，
追究造谣者的法律责任。
这个时候南方的身份是没有公开的，
风波暂时是平息了的。
对，这件事情其实我还有点印象，
当时确实在网上还热了几天，
但是这个事情很快热度就过去了，
因为南方不知道是谁，
然后景天这方也没有去承认这个事情，
所以当时大家就当做是一个传言，
就这么听了一下。
到了第二阶段，
那就是全面引爆，
多位娱乐博主重新翻出了5月份的事件，
把90后神秘富豪直接锁定为孙宇辰。
就直到这个时候才把这两件事情联系到一块吗？
对，也就这个月月底，
话题就是景天富豪男友疑似孙宇辰，
孙宇辰我的女友景天，
也就是大家在最近看到的热搜。
这个时候还是没有同框照片这样的恋情出现实锤的，
其实是没有的。
到了傍晚8月27号傍晚18点53分，
孙宇辰的代理律师张启淮发布了微博，
公布了整个案件事实说明，
孙宇辰因相关的财产争议，
以警谋及其父母为被告提起民事诉讼，
涉案标是大概3000多万元。
同时律师还确认了涉案3000多万元的性质是彩礼，
两个人之前是情侣，
上半年分了手，
核心的诉求就是分手了，
你把钱还我，
起诉书当中没有提到戴运的话题。
他的原话是，
戴运也是事实，
但我们诉讼请求里没有提及这个事。
大约12分之后景天工作室就发布了一个声明。
对，然后声明的权文跟大家介绍一下，
声明是这么说的，
他说声誉是一人的生命也是一人的软肋，
但我们有勇气对以一人声誉为腰斜的碰瓷行为说不，
秉承相信法律一切遵从法定程序的原则，
我们无意占用公共资源一切交给法院处理，
除公布后续维权进展其他问题不再回应。
他相当于就是给这件事定了性叫碰瓷，
对,
当天晚上孙宇辰就在外网平台发布了6000字长文，
我的女友景天，
自称自己是画了十几个小时，
两个晚上几乎没睡写成的。
当时人在不担有时差，
白天处理公务，
凌晨无人打扰的时候就动笔写文，
文末还标注了本文纯属虚构如有雷统，
迟属巧合。
我觉得这个行为就很贱，
其实我说句实话，
就故意搞人吗？
对,
就是你故意写一个这种长文，
然后里面又写的很多一些风花雪月的本来，
就是大家对于娱乐明星对于这些尤其像这样漂亮的女明星，
都会有一些狭想对吧？
那你现在又写出这样的一些东西，
然后让大家就是浮想连篇，
包括最近这个长文真的已经被网友玩的，
就是各种各种各样，
甚至都已经出了那种AI的短句来复原这个这个情况，
然后我们简单的来看一下，
就是他在这个长文里面讲到的一些核心的内容，
但是这些我们还是要说明，
全部都是孙宇辰单方面的陈述，
没有经过任何的证实，
2007年孙宇辰称，
刚进北大的时候在QQ广告上看到了景田代言的图片，
并且保存在校内网发起了一个好友的申请，
写了山山的写弄了40分钟，
最后只发出一句你好未被通过，
此后19年换设备都保留了这张照片，
每转一笔钱就在想着，
到了什么程度他会通过，
第一个10亿想过，
100亿也想过。
在恋爱期，
根据孙宇辰长文并且双方的口径拼图，
2025年12月到2026年年初，
两个人居称在香港，
有第一次见面，
随后就相恋，
恋爱的时长的各方口径不太一样，
根据孙宇辰的长文，
自述大约是三个月就谈婚论嫁了，
但是他律师张启怀对于凤凰网娱乐称，
大概有七个多月，
双方父母都见过面，
达成婚约有这个意象，
另外媒体早期的报道称有三年多，
总之这个时间各方口径是不太一样的，
另外长文也提到了一些奢华的交往细节，
比方说，
包场看电影的时候，
遇到已经购票的观众直接递给人家现金让人走，
还有出行带了二三十个人的团队，
包空客A330，
因为普通的公务机太小了，
弯流,
G700四人飞机整月待命，
文中还写到他们从来没有见过这么大的四人飞机等等，
包海岛度假，
洛杉矶蒙泰期，
拉古纳海滩酒店包整层三十天花了100万美元，
为了他的隐私，
而他住了八天就走了，
这都是长文当中写到的一些细节，
孙宇辰还长文自称，
曾经委托机构队景天做了四十多页的静置调查，
最后说我还是选择相信他，
就很欠啊，
就是运气真的，
我觉得他就是太会擅长去炒作自己了，
知道大家喜欢看什么，
到今年的1月2号，
孙宇辰在马尔代夫向景天求婚，
随后通过父母银行转账转出了3000万财力，
主要是打入到了景天父亲的账户，
部分转入景天以及景天母亲的账户，
律师说全部是银行正规转账，
资金、轨迹、清晰完整。
关于行程的对照，
也是被网友们拿出来一条一条地进行对比。
2025年12月份在香港的归例酒店，
2026年1月西班牙特内里费岛利斯卡尔顿，
景天1月16号也发布一个微博，
就是旅途的风景能够对得上。
再就是1月底到2月份马尔代夫索尼瓦甲尼岛，
2月13号景天是有看海的组图，
粉色的长裙，
包括标志性的入海滑梯的水屋，
再到3月份在加州蒙特齐拉谷纳海滩。
孙宇辰长文当中的路线，
包括景天公开的度假照，
在时间和顺序上都是连续能够对应得上的。
对，我看到有一个说法，
你看你刚刚在提到这些酒店名字，
它其实都特别的绕口，
对吧，都特别的复杂。
但是这个孙宇辰在长文当中，
他就把这个东西写得非常非常详细。
我看到有一个说法，
就说他就是故意，
就是因为你东西越详细，
越真实，
他越真实，
越能够对照上，
越能够去佐证，对吧。
分手的导火索是两个人计划带运，
但这里要特别说明带运在咱们中国大陆是违法行为。
孩子预计2027年出生，
景天赴美取卵安，
在电话当中索要5000万美金，
并且是现金。
文中说道到了诊所，
景天说没有5000万就不取。
孙宇辰说这是他第一次没有立刻答应他，
他说了一句让我想想，
第二天景天回店，
随后没有人再见过他了。
然后这里面还有一件事情特别有意思，
就是孙宇辰当时在做出这个决定，
就不给景天5000万这个决定的时候，
居然是用AI来决定的。
哦，他是问的AI。
就是现在我们很多人在日常的办公或者生活当中就习惯问AI，
但是没有想到孙宇辰的这个level就是这个级别，
他还是要问AI。
他当时是说他是问了这个cloud，
就是把所有的现金资产跑了一遍。
然后AI告诉他的结论是对他不会有任何影响，
就是给5000万美金。
但是他问AI说该不该给，
cloud的回答是对于爱情我不关心也不理解，
但是你不能把这5000万美元给他。
然后孙宇辰就说，
让我毛过悚然的不是他聪明是AI一点犹豫都没有，
就给出了他这样的一个答案。
但是我最近又看到了有一些博主在调侃这个事情，
他说好像有网友做了实验，
就是用其他的一些AI去回答同样的这个问题。
就其他的所有的AI都回答的是可以给。
真的吗？
只有cloud的回答是不能给。
然后他们说有没有一种可能，
就是孙宇辰其实也问了很多的AI，
但是最后选了个。
但是最后选了一个不给的，
并且把最终做出这个决定的责任。
好吧。
对给了AI，
但是当然因为我们自己没有去做实验，
但是我在网上有看到大家有些截图，
就是比如问豆包等等等等。
但是大家都知道豆包是属于讨好行的。
对，你跟豆包说，
怎么怎么样，
豆包顺着你的话说。
对,
所以这个就是一个怎么说，
在当中大家调侃一个点，
如果大家有兴趣的话，
也可以自己去试着问一下自己的AI。
但是他如果在众多AI当中选择了一个最符合自己想法的，
那倒是还蛮有趣的。
但是我们也知道，
就是大家在网上肯定最近也刷到了，
其实这个文章有非常多的私密细节。
其实我们在这里就没有去把那一部分内容做表述。
我们只想整个的流程。
对，包括称呼什么妈妈等等这种吧。
其实我觉得我个人觉得是，
他这个也算是一种文字暴力。
其实就像因为我在网上也看到网友说，
叫做用最廉价的文字毁掉一个女演员最尊贵的体面。
就是我觉得这件事情其实很可怕，
就是当有一个人他去写了一篇长文，
然后把你指名道姓的带入到这个长文当中，
甚至这个长文当中所有的这些内容，
当然我们现在也不去评判，
我们也没有办法评判他是真的还是假的。
但是你在长文当中所有写的这些香焰的内容，
这些很私密的这些内容，
就会让大家对这个人浮想连篇。
更可怕的是，
当事人自己就是比如说在这件事当中景田，
他没有办法自证，
他也没有办法出来，
或者甚至说他也不可能自证出来说，
他写的不是这样，没有发生过这个事情。
不好说。
对，不好说，
他也没有办法说，也没有办法去佐证。
最后就变成了大家对于景田的这个一个外在的形象，
那就被定性在了就是他之前发生过的这些事情。
比如说什么妈妈啊等等这些啊。
我觉得这是蛮可怕的，
其实就是孙隐晨在这件事情上，
我该说不说就是做这样的事情是蛮下作的。
就是故意的呀，
对,
就是故意的，
就是为了炒作自己，
然后把这个利益最大化，
对吧,
就是他们之间说了嘛，
孙隐晨就是从来不做那种亏本的事情，
所有的每一笔钱花的都是要值，
包括今天我们在说到这个三千万彩礼的时候，
很多人也给他说就是叫警退款嘛，
没想到警退款的风都吹到了娱乐圈，
对吧,
就是给的彩礼结果现在又要退掉，
但是你在这个过程当中，
你跟这个女明星之间的这些互动什么的你也获得了，
结果现在你说要退钱啊，
并且大家都说他是拿这篇文章来买抖家，
对,
是吧,
就是其实也是把流量转化到自己身上，
对,
所以我觉得我们真的不想在节目里面去把那些细节去，
当做一个花边新闻或者一个什么样的风花雪月的事情跟大家分享，
然后在那里说啊你看多好笑，
那些是大家在网上你们自己去刷的时候都可以刷得到，
但是在我们节目当中我觉得去讲那些事情很恶心，
你知道吗，
陈述新闻是最好，
所以刚刚我们就只是分享了就是孙宇辰说到的一些他们的这个比如说交往的一些，
就是他自己所说的交往的这样的一些时间线等等的，
我们大概跟大家讲一下，
让大家大概知道发生了些什么事情，
好不好，
那我们接下来就来继续往下看，
当天晚上张继科直播撞车，
啊这个也是巧合，
因为张继科照常是每周四都会有一个抖音的固定直播，
很多人以为他是故意的，
但其实不是对，
他已经持续五个多星期以上了，
这个直播间的人数呢平时就几千，
当天晚上是飙到了十万以上，
弹幕就被各种问题刷屏，
有网友就翻出当年景田和张继科微博互动当中，
兔兔主人这个称呼还在继续玩梗，
张继科全程都是冷处理，
一边啃玉米一边反复强调，
不知道的问题自己不能回答，
没看跟自己没关系，
并且给出一个精妙的类比，
就像你问一道高三的高考数学题，
我只能回答你俩字不会，
三个字不知道，
随后强行把话题拉回到，
张继科张继科碑有多少人参赛，
基地孩子的考学情况，
为避免舆论发酵提前下播，
没有发任何声明也没有评价孙宇辰和景田任何一句，
就在这件事情当中你知道吗？
就是一个男人的处理，
对张继科反而又获得了一些路人员，
就是因为在之前大家也知道张继科和景田发生的那些传闻或者是一些事情，
对吧当时其实大家对于张继科的整个的形象，
包括那个的诟病是很多的，
结果在这件事情当中反而让大家觉得，
张继科的处理才是比较体面的，
并且他的账号当天还涨了粉，
对就是当然很多人也会觉得说是不是故意的，
就是在这个舆论最大的时候刚好开播，
但是刚刚我们也说了什么他其实之前一直自己有在常规的在做直播，
而且他在这个直播当中也没有去蹭这个热度，
没有对吧他不像是某些酸辣粉，
大家知道吧，酸辣粉一出事人就来了对吧，
大S和酸辣粉那一家出事的时候酸辣粉是怎么做的，
大家都知道真正玩流量就是去很下作的方式去获取流量的行为是什么样，
但是我觉得张继科在这个当中反而是没有做出那样的事情，
落井下石还是很卑劣是真的，
好到第四阶段就是8月28号今天本人开始发声，
原文是我过去现在未来都不会为钱出卖我的爱情，
更不会出卖我的灵魂，
我依然相信爱情，
我依然眼光不行，
我依然智慧欠风，
但我相信法律，
相信善良，
相信终究会有正义和公平，
时间会证明一切，
整个的回复原文没有谈到任何的事实细节，
也不接对方的叙事框架，
并且他的姿态放低，
但立场非常的坚毅，
所以有大违评价，
他说依然眼光不行这6个字就伤了两个人，
他就我刚刚提到张继柯嘛对对对，
这就是他这两件事情我觉得好像有一点类似有一点点，
你发现吗张继柯之前也是欠钱，
然后还说有拍私密视频什么的发给别人，
然后这一次的这个男的孙宇辰又是，
把他们俩的一些私密细节公之于众，
去做这种我觉得挺瞎做的说实话，
但这个第二个是孙宇辰他自己发的嘛，
张继柯那个好像还是说有传闻是那样做对吧，
有传闻就是他把这个东西抵给了债主对对对对，
其实性质差不多嘛，
只是没有公开发出来而已嘛对吧，
但是都是好像南方会去透露这些私密细节和这些东西，
对女生的伤害其实是非常大的，
在景田进行公开回复之后，
孙宇辰有接受密集受访，
跟这个常文的真实性还有虚构都有标注，
说绝大多数我觉得是符合我意愿的一个真实的陈述，
在文中写的是虚构的，
因为我也没有办法保证每个东西都是100%，
但至少说我自己是怎么想的我怎么说的，
这一点是100%确认的，
关于起诉的动机，
他说第一个是律师的建议，
第二个是也有点讽刺的感觉，
这个可能是我们两个之间唯一的联系了，
除了这件事也没有别的联系，
光想这个事情其实对我的消耗都挺大的，
也否认自己营销炒作，
他还否认啊，
说自己发文的动机很简单，
说案件已经立案，
双方都是公众人物，
信息会迟早进入到公众的视野，
与其外界拼凑不如我自己探称表达。
我觉得很恶心的一点，
按照正常逻辑来说，
如果是你们之间因为财理发生了矛盾，
发生了打官司，
那你可以发一篇文章去缠述我与景田女士，
或者我与景女士相识的一些就怎么认识的，
然后我们之前曾经做了一些什么，
就是一些形成或者当时怎么谈这个事的，
我觉得这些或许还可以说，
你是就是你把它公开出来，
算是对于你们之间这个官司，
我觉得是可以有一个补充说明，
是的,
但是你在这个当中讲到那么细节的一些事情，
对吧,
大家应该有都看到什么浙安娜的，
我们就不说了，
我觉得有必要嘛，
就是明显就是为了蹭流量，
蹭热度去炒作嘛，
好，话说到这儿，
就会有一些延伸梗和商业效应了，
因为这个富豪版警退款的事件刚刚我们讲过了，
孙宇辰舍得花钱，
但钱绝不能白花的这个过往的形象，
权往细成本次起诉是警退款，
刚刚也提到了，
然后张晓权躺赢，
因为常文当中说到这个摩芝加的细节，
对应的是中华老字号张晓权，
就被网友封为芝加刀概念股，
8月28号开盘股价一度，
暴涨超过11%，
一张减好芝加想摸哪里摸哪里的品牌海报风传，
这个海报你看了吗？
我看到了，
我不是转给你了吗？
对对对，
我看到是因为你转给我的，
我当时第一感觉看到其实我是很反感的说实话，
我是觉得这世界疯了，
对,
我是觉得说这个对品牌是一个好的嘛，
我觉得反正我看上去我不知道大家的感觉，
这就是蹭流量蹭热度，
我觉得我反而对这个品牌没有好感了，
我觉得很恶心，
对吧?
张小璇客服是这么回应的，
说这是网友的二创，
不是官方发布，
对世界没有立场也不予置评，
一分钱广告费都没花白减的上亿的曝光，
对,
如果我觉得这个是官方做的，
那真的我对这个品牌好感全无，
但如果像客服所说的，
是网友自己去玩梗弄的话，
那我也只能说这个网友真的是非常的，
这个不好评，
这个网友为什么不能是这个公司的人呢？
反正这个就真不知道了，
对对这个没办法，
就是暂时没办法合适了，
还有一些司法梗，
比方说孙宇辰说景田主动体的带孕，
孙宇辰回应为何没有用豆包，
这样的话题，
留言也很大，
就最近的这个关于这件事情，
围绕着他的热搜太多了，
太多了，
反正刚刚我们也跟大家基本上把从头到尾，
包括他们俩怎么认识，
怎么会有交集，
然后当中到底发生了什么事儿，
跟大家基本上讲完了，
我相信大家听完之后，
应该也都知道是这么个事儿了，
后面再去看其他的一些延伸出来的热搜等等也好，
那肯定也就知道，
就是比较看得明白吧。
对于这个事情，
法律是怎么来看的呢？
我们来讲一讲法律界的一个基础的解读，
浙江风国律师事务所陈松涛律师说，
孙宇辰发布长文已经涉嫌侵犯景田的人格权和名誉权，
也就是文末标注的这个纯属虚构，
也不能够掩盖内容直接指向了景田这个特定自然人的客观事实。
他完全作为一个民事行为能力人，
明知发布会导致景田社会评价降低，
还主动发布，
主观过错很明显，
并且相关的话题已经造成了社会评价明显降低的一个实际后果，
符合侵权全部法定构成的要件。
关于景田是否会被判为劣迹艺人呢？
这个可能在我们圈子里会比较重要了，
涉及到之后还能不能曝光，
那本案只是日常生活当中常见的一个财力反环的纠纷，
涉案金额大，
当事人有公众关注度而已。
劣迹艺人通常认定是要违法犯罪，
或者是严重违反了公蓄良俗，
这个案件目前还在一个管辖权的异议阶段，
没有生效判决，
也不存在劣迹的定性，
不会直接触发禁播令。
但是我要说一句，
大部分媒体在选择艺人的时候会多放考虑，
就算说不能是劣迹艺人还是会有影响，
一定会有影响的，
对节目对内容其实还是会很谨慎的，
因为你的形象已经，
就是我们再说到一个艺人吧，
我举个例子就是白白河，
对吧，白白河当年说句实话，
他当时被偷拍到的那张照片，
就是一纸蚕，我们叫做对吧，
也蛮恶臭的，这个称呼，
就是所谓的当时的那个照片，
其实说实在话又怎么了呢，
他只是一个私下的一个行为，
然后被你偷拍到了，
但是对吧，
因为白白河他其实也没有被认定为劣迹艺人，
没有对吧，
后面我们看到他其实也还有作品，
但是对于艺人的伤害度真的非常的大，
在这里其实我还要再补充一个，
这个也在我们的稿子里没写，
但是我最近这几天一直在思考这个问题就是，
对于女明星的这样的一个道德标准的约束和要求，
好像似乎就是比男明星要高很多，
对吧，男明星某某某某，
就是我就不举例子了，
之前出过了这个事情那个事情那个事情对吧，
我也不好举例子，
会被骂不展开不展开，
现在依然在该上综艺的上综艺该干嘛的干嘛，
演化剧的演化剧的化剧该开演唱会开演唱会，
但是女明星你像我刚刚举的白白河，
你说他有什么很大的过错吗？
你刚刚说这个时候我还在搜我想到京城，
就是那个交通的那个事情好像最后也没有怎么样，
但是他也是被好像女明星稍微有一点点这种东西，
就会被感觉好像就是不行了，
你这个形象崩塌了，
对，好像女明星他本来就是一个女神的形象，
结果突然一下崩塌了之后，
以后只要淡粉你上节目，
人家就会来想到这个事情对吧，
白白河只要上节目会出现到公众场合，
我在网上经常刷到，
就是大家首先第一反应就是白白河当时的那个手指的那个，
但是它又怎样呢就是反正有时候对吧，
就是大家对于女明星他的这个约束道德要求就是更高，
但是往往我们最近有在看很多演唱会对不对，
你也有在看很多演唱会我也是啊，
你会发现包括在这个演唱会的状态，
包括演唱会的这种用心的程度，
包括身材管理，
包括所有这些女明星他很多时候往往，
当然我们不是一棍子打死，
他往往比很多的男明星就是做得要好，
你像蔡依林啊或者等等对吧，
他到了这样的一个年龄，
你想想一个40多岁的男明星，
他往往在综艺节目当中或者在这个影视剧作品当中，
他呈现出来是什么样的一个身材状态，
但是往往女明星比如剩下梁靖茹，
我最近有看到梁靖茹，孙燕滋，张辉妹到了这个年龄，
他身材有变化，
往往大家就会有很大的恶意说，
啊怎么会变成这样子了，
那男明星发福的那肚子挺的那里的一大堆，
那脸发塞的成那个样子，
但是为什么大家对女明星好像就一定要求，
就是但不是所有的人都能像，
比如说像蔡依林或者等等，
就是他们这么自律到这样的一个程度，
但是你对他的要求就是有这么的高，
我觉得他维持的好是没问题的，
但他没有维持，
或者他没有维持好，
也没有问题啊，
人家生了小孩儿人家当了妈妈，
人家有自己的生活，
或者人家因为一些一些情绪或者等等方面的一些问题，
他需要去治疗或者怎么样，
导致身材的一个变化，
又怎样的你是去听他的歌，
你又不是为了他在你那里就是怎么身材很好来的表现自己怎么样，
哎呦我是觉得说往往大家对于女明星，
他就是会有很严苛的这种要求和眼光，
我前几天看到Celina也是往上拍他的照片，
我就想说那怎样的Celina他不能有自己正常的生活吗，
他一定就是要白又瘦的那种感觉，
他还是40岁50岁你还要求一个女明星白又瘦吗，
那Celina他不能够有自己的生活，
他在自己很舒适的状态里面，
他就是会有大家都只有一个有个词叫幸福肥嘛，
对吧或者怎么样，
他就是会那样子很正常他开心就好，
而且很多时候大家对于女明星，
尤其像Coco这样的事情发生之后，
大家其实有时候会觉得说，
哎你只要开开心心的活着就好了，
但是非要到那一步才会这么觉得，
永远不能够提前预知，
我觉得这也是网络暴力的一部分，
对，那他还在活着的时候，
为什么你们要去对他进行身材的羞辱，
对他进行这样的批判，
等到有一天他不在了，
才会想着说哎呀他只要活着就好了，
就是但是大家对于男明星没有这方面的科科，
或者比较少一点吧，
少一点哦，
没有谁，
余文乐今年出来的时候大家也在说他，
但是会少一点，
不像女明星那么多，
就是不是说完全没有，
但是会相对少很多我觉得，
就这个问题我在最近这几天一直在看景田的这个事情，
和那个时候我就在想说一篇文章，
就能够毁掉一个女明星所有的给大家带来的这些神秘感，
或者说给大家带来的这个很可怕，
改天哪天我写一个小坎的把千字长文，
你也没有办法去证实啊，
你没有办法去证实任何嘛，
所以我那天看到一个评论好像是耳帝说的还是谁，
就说大家都活在一个魔幻的世界，
就是你想，
你希望这个世界你想象这个世界是什么样，
它就是什么样，
就大家永远不会去追求真相，
或者很多真相是无法被追求到，
但我觉得这个事情分两个部分看，
第一个是这个世界本身它是一个爱情世界，
就是如果我们今天把孙宇辰变成一个男A，
景田变成一个B，
说白了就是谈恋爱，
就是谈恋爱然后最后没有成，
对那谈恋爱当中没有那么多对和错，
它就是当下的感觉，
你是爱美也好，
当时说下的狠话也好，
它就是两个人自己的感受，
然后最后没谈成也很正常，
对吧最后本来我给了你财理，
最后没有谈成我现在要求你把财理访还，
好多还有毁婚的呢，
对这不是有是一个很正常的过程吗，
对所以它就是一个爱情世界，
只是说孙宇辰可能会有营销的成分在里头，
但是都不重要，
它就是一个爱情，
所以就简单看就好，
但是我们希望，
因为不知道这个事后面还会怎么发展，
我希望还是能够真的让真相浮出水面吧，
不然白白毁掉一个人也是挺无奈的，
好吧接下来我们看一下包贝尔的这个事吧，
包贝尔疑似出轨，
8月26号有一段视频显示包贝尔可以名红发女子，
先后进入到同一家火锅店吃饭，
凌晨1点左右红发女子就先回到了酒店房间，
几分钟之后包贝尔就来到了门前，
拉上走廊的窗帘进入房间，
一直到第二天早上的8点才离开，
截至目前包贝尔本人工作室包括妻子包门镜都没有做任何的公开回应，
并且包门镜的社交账号已经设置为，
警户官的人才可以评论，
所有的报道都是疑似都来自于自媒体单方面的爆料没有官方媒体独立的核实，
所以说目前没有实锤，
所以我们说的都是疑似疑似，
感情的事件我们来梳理一下疑似出轨的男主包贝尔1984年出生，
黑龙家哈尔滨人北电毕业，
曾经自爆14岁同时交往了7个女朋友，
这一段我还看到过，
是吧,
这一段我是看到她上了一个访谈节目里面自己亲口说的，
自己说的，
我看了这一段，
此前那是曾经两次被拍到有出轨，
都没有公开回应，
然后原配妻子包门镜87年出生，
辽宁府圣人北电毕业2005年的时候主动追求包贝尔，
陪她北漂8年住这个出租屋，
14年的时候结婚，
25年的时候5月官宣二太出生，
然后就到了2016年柳言事件，
当时力挺自己的丈夫还说包贝尔最帅，
柳言事件是在2016年3月30号的时候，
他们俩包门镜和包贝尔是在巴黎岛补办婚礼，
柳言是半娘，
接亲的环节当中包贝尔就提议把半娘要推入到水里，
半郎团韩庚杜海涛王祖兰就合力抬起了，
穿着抹胸纱裙的柳言，
想要把它扔进泳池，
柳言是惊恐尖叫，
拼命反抗，
同为半娘的假灵冲上前，
用身体挡住了半郎，
以发红包来打原厂，
才阻止了这个闹绝生机。
现场这个视频流出之后，
全往华然，
率先公开道歉的是柳言。
这件事情也真的很离谱，
就是我又回到了我刚刚所说的，
就大家对于女明星往往更加的可可，
那么当时出现这个事情之后，
居然是柳言出来道歉说我错了，
不好意思对不起。
他说我第一次受到了惊吓，
我当半娘第一次，
然后像婚礼主人这个致歉，
包贝尔当天晚上是发偿问道歉，
说我原本的设计是私民牌，
但是因为我的衣服被海关扣了，
所以才改为这个下水对抗，
我觉得这个就很说不过去。
你那个私民牌和下水对抗是一回事吗？
关键是广州海关官方微博还回应我们不背锅，
因为你们那个宾客穿着那个带名牌的衣服，
就是没有我没有扣留你，
对，这个私民牌衣服没到位什么的，
25年的时候就有网友在包贝尔的评论区，
要求他要向留言道歉，
然后包贝尔还抱粗口怒怼他，
删除评论设置了账号私密。
对，这个我也看了，
这件事情其实当时也是蛮昭黑的，
我觉得包贝尔反正怎么说呢，
在大家的公众的印象当中，
绝大部分嘛，
反正我在网上看到的，
我不知道也是不是因为信息检防，
我不在网上看到绝大部分对他的好感都很低，
包括电影作品好像也没有特别处圈的，
这个爆料是来自于刘大锤，
刘大锤大家应该很熟悉了，
经常爆料，
然后刘大锤说是本意是敦守其他艺人，
但是跟包贝尔同住的酒店意外拍到了是一个巧合。
对，这个我看到了，
他本来不是拍他的，
对，他是这么说的，
对，包括这个设施女子之前一直很多人说，
他是不是什么特殊职业或者等等的，
但是后面有英武也有看到很多新闻说，
什么他们还一起出去吃了饭，
吃了饭之后然后再回房间，
我当时英武在我们的听友群里面，
其实大家也在讨论这个事儿，
当时大家就说，
是不是什么特殊职业或者找的谁谁谁，
然后我说不对吧，
因为正常来说应该不会，
就如果说特殊职业，
可能应该不会一块吃饭，
一块吃火锅，
而且不会就是好几次，
对吧,
后面又查出来好像说是跟包贝尔是2024年。
在成都的一场饭局里面认识的，
然后说身边的人员都知晓他的存在，
也就是说这个人他们是早就认识的，
对,
包文静对包贝尔其实爱的非常深，
就在多个平台都能看到他很喜欢包贝尔，
曾经他也发过骂小三的博文，
并且包贝尔还回复了包文静骂小三的博文说懒得理你，
他们说包贝尔是，
我不知道你看了那个吃米吗电影，
没有,
那个电影我去看了，
我不知道有多少听众是看了吃米的，
吃米里面的男主角他是用了许愿柳，
就是让那个女主角就疯狂的爱上自己，
他们说包贝尔是中国使用许愿柳第一人，
是那个鬼片吗？
对,
那我看了，
而且最好笑的是什么吗？
在那个剧里面男主角也叫贝尔，
哦对,
那个男主，
他的名字叫贝尔，
然后包贝尔也叫贝尔，
所以他们说包贝尔是使用许愿柳，
就是因为我们在很多的综艺和访谈节目当中，
我会发现包贝尔超级无比吃米和深爱着包贝尔上头，
对,
非常非常上头，
但我觉得也好了，
如果爱情就是这样，
对对对，
当然这个我觉得就是喜欢谁或者怎么样，
我觉得这个其实挺好的，
然后但是在很多的那个综艺里面好像，
哎好像我看到他们当时结婚的时候，
就是那个包贝尔哭的，
就说我就是跟定你了，
或者怎么就是我不能离开你，
然后反正就说的，
爱得很深，
很深很深，
两个人是05年的时候在北天校园相识的，
然后开启了爱情长炮，
13年包贝尔向包文静求婚，
15年女儿包可爱，
就是饺子出生，
16年在巴黎岛补办正式婚礼，
24年年底官宣怀了二胎，
到了2025年二胎儿子出生，
一家四口很圆满，
嗯,
啊,
然后结果没想到出了这样的事情，
是,
关于这个事情目前是疑似嘛，
所以其实并没有定性，
所以我们从法律的角度先来说一说，
审言就是偷拍本身可能是违法的，
这个狗仔蹲人拍私人形成，
这个就涉嫌违法，
即便是公众人物，
酒店入住包括私下出行，
这个跟公共利益无关的私生活，
都是有隐私权的，
民法典是明确有规定，
刺探拍摄公开他人的私密活动，
属于侵犯隐私权，
肖像权，
并且在今年新修订的这个治安管理处罚法，
已经把跟踪和偷拍他人隐私明确列为违法行为了，
第二个就进入房间不等于出轨嘛，
对,
这个就是为什么我们在整个讲述这一段都是叫疑似，
因为他进入房间也不代表对吧，
对,
不是代表一定发生了什么，
如果传播的这个信息最终被证伪，
就是它是个假的，
或者视频有着剪辑的误导，
那转发评论当中那些断言式表达，
可能就是侵权链条的一部分，
这就是涉及到各位网友了，
这个特别留意，
第三个就是公众人物不是完全没有隐私，
也包括锦田那个也是公众人物，
只是把它搬到了台面上来说对吧，
酒店走廊虽然说是一个办公共的区域，
但是拉窗帘这个动作恰恰说明当事人是有隐私期待的，
不管这个视频内容最终是真是假，
偷拍的方式来曝光私人关系，
这个答案都是否定的，
它是不被法律和社会所鼓励的。
是,
反正这个事吧就是大家都知道就是有这么一个事情了，
我觉得，
然后,
当然我还是想回到前面我们聊的那个话题里面就是，
我且要看看宝贝尔在后续的这个影视或者说娱乐圈里面的活跃，
就是如果是这个事情我在想说，
他是一个女明星，
对,
今天一个女明星跟一个男的进了酒店拉上窗帘，
然后会干嘛，
那大家对于这个女明星的羞辱或者对于他的这个对吧，
各种的一些一些想象会是怎么样，
那这个女明星后续在娱乐圈我估计大概率就是也就是查不此人，
或者没有资源，
即便说我们刚才也说到了他在房间里也并不代表能够证明什么，
对,
那今天这个事情发生的是宝贝尔是一个男明星，
当然也是没有办法证明什么嘛，
对吧,
因为到现在为止其实都没有任何回应，
也没有后续了，
对,
就不说了，
然后呢，
所以在后续的这个娱乐圈当中我们且看，
就是他还能怎么样，
我看到很多网友的那个评论就是其实也是挺伤的，
就大家真的在对对这种信息的时候，
吃个瓜就可以了，
就真的不要是过度的解读和评价，
就是因为我觉得我在想就是那个走进那个房间的那个女生，
如果真的就是一个普通的，
他们只是在聊事情，
我打个比方，
他看到这样的热搜，
他心里得是多么泛江倒海，
我不敢想，
反正我觉得可能大家对于就是这种男艺人的宽容度就是比较高吧，
我觉得这个事情对宝贝尔的影响没有说非常非常大，
我说句实话，
当然网友们对于他的这个会有情绪是因为，
大家早就看到不顺眼了，
说实话就是宝贝尔，
因为他之前结婚的时候那个事情其实也很昭黑了，
大家只不会觉得说他是已经，
好像有一个说法说什么，
废墟就是他无可他是吗？
哦哦哦，
就是他还能踏到什么程度，
对对对，
就人家踏房，
他就是已经就是一对废墟了，
还能怎么踏，
而且他经常就是导演的电影，
然后包括参与的电影，
好像票房口碑都非常非常差，
只是大家就是借这个事情，
大家会觉得说终于，
终于到你了，
对吧终于那个，
好好,
继续我们要关注到同样是公众人物的刘祥，
大家可以一起来看一下，
可能刚刚实际上还在说是不是不一定大家都认识刘祥，
我感觉很多年轻的朋友是不是或许会认识，
但是可能对于刘祥的感觉或者感受没有我们这一代人那么深，
因为我们真的是感觉在那个经济上行期，
然后刘祥的出现，
就是好像会给大家给国人非常大的一个引领的，
这么一个积极向上的感觉，
很提气，
很自豪，
是,
所以我们就先来认识一下刘祥，
简单的来介绍一下他的职业生涯和他的推议情况，
让他是1983年7月13号出生在上海的，
是中国男子110米兰的运动员，
曾经也是中国国家田径队的一名队员，
是中国体育史上和亚洲田径史上，
非常具有代表性的跨岚运动员，
所以在这一期的节目里面，
其实我也用到了一个更，
就是刘祥也有跨不去的看，
就是他对作为一个110米兰的非人，
他也有跨不去的看，
就是最近发生的这个事情，
那他在2004年雅典奥运会的男子110米兰的决赛当中，
以12秒91的成绩夺冠，
这个成绩是追平了当时的世界纪录，
并且打破了奥运会的纪录，
所以因此成为了中国男子田径项目奥运冠军的重要代表人物，
因为在那个之前，
中国在田径项目上一直都是成绩，
没有那么理想的，
因为大家都知道田径都被欧美或者是非洲的那些包览了，
所以他的出现当时就是非常给大家振奋的，
然后到了2015年4月7号，
刘祥是正式宣布推议，
然后就逐渐的淡出了职业竞技的赛场，
也就是为什么就是大家好像已经很多年没怎么听到他的消息了，
确实,
然后在8月26号就前几天，
刘祥发微博公开求助，
求助什么呢？
他首先是晒出了04年雅典奥运会奥运会奏冠时候的1363号号码牌，
配文称，
在线等碰到个难题，
希望广大网友给我点建议，
体育局让我买断或当教练上班，
我该怎么办？
随后刘祥就进一步表达了自己的困惑，
他是说退役10年之后突然被要求安置，
无论选择买断还是当教练都让他感到非常的迷茫，
刘祥还表示说自己年龄偏大，
没有直教经验，
担心当教练的话会误人前途，
这条公开求助就迅速的引发了网友们的讨论，
然后网友的舆论关注点主要集中在两个方面，
就首先第一个就是他退役了10年之后，
为什么还在讨论，
或者还在涉及到运动员安置的问题，
就是大家印象中觉得早就应该解决了，
退役就要安置，
然后第二个就是买断和当教练这两个安排的选择，
他是不是符合相关退役运动员的安置规定，
是这样子，
然后针对这件事情，
上海体育局回应了，
就面对舆论，
他们在8月26号的下午就回应说，
上海市竞技体育训练管理中心已经与刘祥进行了沟通，
根据截图显示，
上海体育局表示说，
将根据国家体育局及上海市关于运动员退役安置的有关规定，
主要通过组织安置或自主责业，
两种方式进行妥善的处理。
这个回应就和刘祥本人此前表达的困惑形成了一个对照，
就是让双方对于退役安置问题的不同理解受到了关注，
就是体育局觉得说，
我们是有这样的一些选择是很妥善的，
但是刘祥他会觉得很困惑，
你这个时候安置我了，
然后刘祥在评论区就做出了回应，
针对于上海体育局的相关说法，
他提出疑问说，
表示自己在退役了10年之后才再次涉及的安置问题，
并反问相关安排是否一直按照规定执行，
刘祥还提到说，
自己之前在拍广告的时候，
并没有按照如今所说的方式进行安置，
这个回应进一步推动了有关退役安置的流程执行时间和双方沟通情况的讨论，
因为好像我看到有说刘祥他的这个广告费一直都还是好多个意义，
对，很高，
然后是要跟体育局来分的，
刘祥的意思其实表达就是说，
那我之前那么多年的广告，
什么一直你们在分钱的时候，
你们没想到说安置，
结果现在过了10年之后突然开始说要安置我了，
我觉得是很值得生气的，
对，是的，
在这个事情持续受到大家关注的时候呢，
国际奥委会是发布了一个内容，
回顾了他的多贯经历，
并且强调12秒91这个奥运记录，
保持至今，
刘祥的竞技成就跟当下特意安置的这样一个争议，
同一时间受到了大家的关注，
也是无形当中放大了这个舆论，
对于传奇运动员现状的关注，
是的,
这个事情其实让我挺悉虚的，
因为在我们这一代人的印象中当年，
刘祥真的是风光无限啊，
真的觉得就是被捧到了，
大家都觉得说真的是非常非常高的一个地位，
在大家心目当中和当时实际的，
在那样的奥运会的这个赛场上，
但是现在突然一下，
他再一次这么多年没有听到他的消息，
突然一下出来说是一个安置的问题，
就突然觉得好像有一种你懂吗，
就是嘻嘻对，
我觉得运动员跟艺人还不太一样，
艺人说这个人拿了多少奖项，
或者多点多少成就，
终身成就奖，
那个有天使地理人和，
但是运动员不是，
运动员是十大时训练出来的，
是熬了无数个日夜拼出来的，
并且他大多数都是突破了人体极限了的，
所以他们拿到的冠军，
我觉得他那个性价比跟艺人，
其他工作人物不太一样，
好，在我拼了命的拿到这个成就之后，
你看刘祥后面还有跟见断裂的那个事儿，
当时也是引发大家很多的讨论，
好像说当时为了让他上赛场是打封闭，
打封闭上去，
对，他真的面对很多，
然后完了以后他确实有广告商业价值，
这个时候你体育局看到了，
你跟人分钱，
到了十年之后你说我要安置你，
要不要买断，
买断这个词可能对于8090你会了解一点，
但是0010就不太懂了，
买断我讲清楚一点，
就是我给你一拖钱，
一笔钱给你，
什么关系都没有了，
这就是买断，
这个其实是很伤人的，
就是当你有利用价值的时候，
你利用我，
当我没有利用价值的时候，
你要抛弃我，
其实就这感觉，
所以刘祥这个事儿，
为什么要在微博上说他是缺钱吗？
我觉得不是，
他是内心的那个劲没缓过来，
他就想蒸口气，
这个事情对于民运动员，
是可以在公共平台发生的，
还有好多现实以及省一级的运动员，
是无处发生吗？
我也想到了这个，
其实有很多很多，
就是大家看到任何的行业都是有金字塔的，
很多的他到奥运会，
到市井赛等等这些比赛上大放光彩，
但是很多的运动员可能他也同样训练了那么多年，
但是最后没有能够走上那样的赛场，
最终他也是面临到一个推议之后的安置就业的问题，
我们其实之前也看到很多的一些新闻，
还有去搓早的，
大家知道吗？
就是有之前的一些民运动员，
还不是其实还不是很普通的运动员，
还是比较拿了奖项的运动员，
现在在早堂子里给人家搓早，
在就是就是其实挺细续，
就有有地方可以发生，
和我想发生都没地儿发生，
那种无奈其实更让人无可奈何，
这确实是很痛苦，
我们也希望这个事情能有一个后续吧，
对希望能够最终得到一个好的妥善的安置吧，
我觉得是这样子，
其实我觉得能够拿到一个就是，
大家都那么满意或者网友都很满意的，
我觉得不太可能，
我个人觉得不太可能，
只是觉得说相对来说妥善一点，
或者说对不要让人太心寒，
对来接下来是关注到湖南衡阳齐东县的一名老人，
这个大家肯定看到了，
在8月17号中午的12点这个老人呢，
因为身体不舒服，
主动进入到了一个奇派店，
这个店主叫肖爱华，
坐在这个门附近的一个椅子上休息，
老人跟任何人都没有过接触，
老人身体出现异常之后，
肖爱华这个店主就主动上前穿服，
因为天气炎热，
店内无空调，
这个店主肖爱华就判断老人可能是中暑，
按照民间的经验把他移植到了门口的通风位置，
肖爱华事后解释，
启动话说，
中暑要见天，
能呼吸新鲜空气，
但是在这个地方我们插播一下，
就是因为他的这个举动，
最后就是被家属抓住了这一点，
这个待会我们后面回来解释，
为什么就家属会一直揪着，
就是说为什么你要把他拖到店外的这个行为，
到底是在就是想要去救他，
还是别的什么原因，
黄轮当中的肖爱华找不到播号的位置，
喊其他人帮忙打了120，
急救车五分钟之后到了，
老人当时还有生命体征，
但最终因为自身的基础性疾病发作，
抢救无效离世，
公安机关核实调查之后，
罗某戏突发就这个老人，
突发疾病死亡，
没有外力伤害，
没有争执冲突，
排除刑事案件。
现场的视频也显示，
肖爱华全程是积极失救，
及时报医，
行为善意正当。
结果没想到后面开始锁培了。
对，这个家属看了监控视频以后，
就觉得这个店主肖爱华失救方式不当，
你为什么要挪他呢？
对于最终的这个死亡结果要负一定责任。
我看到有一个报道上面说，
家属质疑的点说，
你挪到外面就是不想让他死在店里，
他觉得肖爱华第一反应，
并不是去救这个老人，
而是担心老人在店内身亡。
所以对，
这就是为什么我们刚才说，
争议点在于拖出店外的这个行为。
家属是揪着这个点。
但那个时候人家是不舒服啊，
也没有动。
好吧,
来，8月18号第一次正式调解，
罗某家属提出要十万块钱。
参与调解的这个工作人员啊，
就像双方讲了这个法律细则，
根据民法典主张侵权赔偿，
需举证，
你要证明对方有过错，
调解自愿任何一方不同意就要终止。
那郡总显示呢，
肖爱华坚持自己没有过错，
但自愿人道帮扶两千块钱。
罗某家属降到五万块钱之后就不再让步，
调解就暂停了，
考虑到天气炎热，
经过调解人员的建议，
家属当日下午先行活化遗体。
8月19号第二次调解采用的是背对背，
也就是双方没有见面，
罗某的家属将补偿的金额降到了两万块钱，
肖爱华的一名亲属根据当地的风俗援引同类事件，
就提出那就一万五，
此后双方逐渐达成一万九的共识，
并且肖爱华丈夫是当场转账。
对，这个一万九就这么来的，
我当时看到这儿啊，
我都已经很生气了，
我都已经不理解了，
然后我看到评论区有人说，
是因为这个肖爱华一直失眠，
就晚上睡不好，
因为这个是背受困扰，
所以想着我就花点钱了了算了，
无望之在，
当然我在网上也看到很多说法，
就是有记者去采访了附近的一些街坊领理，
就问说这个实际情况，
然后街坊领理就是这个老人，
在这段时间经常到他这儿来打牌，
到他这儿来就是为了打牌干嘛干嘛，
我觉得但是这个跟这个事情本身明没有直接关联了，
你来打牌或者干嘛的对吧？
事件经过媒体报道之后呢，
就有一些核心的争议啊，
就像我们刚刚说的，
你明明就没有过错，
为什么还要支付一万九，
参与调解的启东县红桥街道宗治中心主任，
陈忠就解释，
民事问题是谁主张谁举证，
调解人员没有资格下权为判断，
只能说双方目前没有证据证实有责任，
参与调解的工作人员刘灵刚就强调，
我们没有权力来逼迫别人出钱，
一开始店主一方主动自己提出要给个几千块，
参考同类事件，
调解方案也是店主一方亲属先提出来的，
很有可能也就是想着两个事儿，
对吧，这个相爱华的儿子其实最后也说嘛，
出事之后母亲一直是失眠的，
关于网传的不赔偿把尸体放门口的威胁各方也是各有说法，
店主一方在笔录当中称对方前妻有过类似表达，
但承认确实没有真正的实施，
死者的家属就否认他们说过这一类的言语，
从时间线上看，
签约前一天这个遗体已经火化了，
也不存在说我要停施要挟的条件，
这都是细致末节了，
关键是这个事儿迎来了反转，
事件在登上热搜之后，
舆论就几乎一边倒在了店主一方，
网友们普遍认为无过挫折被迫出嫌稀释，
是对善意的沉重打击，
也模糊了法律责任的边界。
8月24号,
其东当地的企业金泰米业为肖爱华送去了2万块钱的卫文金，
说你们这一家做了好事受了委屈，
8月26号罗勇号在社交平台宣布自讨要包要捐10万块钱，
店主的儿子随后表示愿意拿出一部分捐款资助乡村老人。
给村里修路灯，做一份爱心传递。
舆论关注最终促成了这件事儿的逆转，
就是8月26号的下午，
罗某家属把1万9转回到了肖爱华儿子的账户，
他还有一个备注，
叫退还人道主义补偿款。
当天晚上在当地有关部门的见证下，
双方签证了一个见证书，
罗某的儿子对记者说没有过错是不需要赔偿的，
我们如今认可这一点，
对网友带来的困扰、占用的公共资源表示抱歉。
退款和道歉让这个事件画了一个句号，
但是很多媒体关注到的是基层调解机制，
就为什么会如此调解？
齐东县司法局的相关负责人说，
每年大部分的民事纠纷都会通过调解来解决，
一般都是柔性的，
并且能够有效的欺负民间矛盾的纠纷，
避免案件大量涌入法院或就地计划，
但是也坦言这个度它不好把握。
对，其实这个里面有涉及到一个问题，
我在网上也看到了有一些博主或者是一些网友们的说，
就说你这个事情就就是论事来办，
你就有点类似于我们出了车货，
出了车货之后你该怎么定责怎么定责，
你不需要赔，你一分钱不需要赔，
你该赔的你就赔，
对吧，就这个事情不要扯的不清楚，
但是我觉得这句话就是有点站在。
太过于理论层面或者说是理性层面，
因为我们要考虑到一个点，
就是像这些条件人员其实他们也非常辛苦，
因为我之前做记者的时候也接触过很多，
你想想你每天要调解这些街坊领理的这些事情，
其实真的非常头痛，
这个里面涉及到一个什么问题呢？
它没有办法像我们比如说在大马路上出一个车货，
或者这个事情这样子去客观的调解是因为，
我们在路上可能刮蹭到了一辆车或者碰到了一个车，
我们跟对方没有任何的关系往来，
没有任何的认识，
所以我可以完全客观的就是就事论事，
但是在很多的相证，
它不是这样子的，
在相证它涉及到一个问题就是人和人之间都是认识，
或者它那个你要考虑到很多这方面的一些问题，
对吧,
所以对于条件人员来说他们被夹在这个中间是很难做的，
很有可能就是罗某死者这一方，
家属跟调解的人员他们也是互相认识，
然后肖爱华这边，
店主这边跟他们也是互相认识，
大概都是邻里街坊，
都是在一个地方生活了这么多年的，
你让他们夹在中间去调解，
这个东西其实对他们来说难度很大，
所以在这个过程中很多人可能会去批判或者说去批评，
说这些调解人员怎么调解的，
为什么要这样子获悉你或者什么的，
但是我想说的是调解人员真的也非基层的这些调解人员，
真的非常非常辛苦，
他们工作真的我觉得这些糟心事是挺多的，
也没有办法去真的站在一个非常客观的角度去批判他们，
觉得他们做的不对，
在他们的角度来说其实很难，
真的很难，
一方面是人的因素，
一方面可能跟制度也有关系，
因为我们都知道这个考核它是有一个话节率和满意率的嘛，
就是你一年这个当地的调解要达到百分之多少多少，
所以它有的时候是必须要牺牲一些内容的，
它有时候它的压力也很大，
要换这个和解也很大你知道吧，
所以可能在这个过程中就是说出于人道主义的那个要不要赔偿一点点钱，
就这样子就两个事儿两个事儿，
但是只是说在这个事情当中可能对方我觉得过问题，
我个人觉得我只代表个人看法，
我觉得就是家属方可能这个口子开的有点太大了你知道吧10万，
就是适当的在当下我仅代表说在当下在那样的一个村正的社会环境当中，
作为大家就是熟人社会熟人关系的这样一个环境当中，
你适当的给一点点比如说个几千块钱或者等等的这样的一个就是服卫金人道主义的这个没问题，
我觉得问题并不大，
但是只是说家属方应该自己有一个判断，
觉得说这个钱我应不应该要这么多，
或者说我应不应该要我觉得问题是在这里就没办法，
这个在这种熟人社会里面就是很多时候就是这样的，
法理和情理它不好变形，
对对就是这样，
当然还有前面有人说，
当时好像说他们当地的那个是哪个部门好像说要赔这笔钱吧，
当时提出了一个质疑就是你不应该用纳税人的钱来做这件事情，
我觉得这个但是很重要的，
对吧就是你再怎么样，
这个是调解也好或者怎么样也好，
你不应该拿着纳税人拿着工价的钱来给这件事情做赔偿，
我觉得这个不能公对私，
对你这个就是不对的，
好不好你不管是像罗永浩的捐款或者谁的给你钱这个都是私人行为，
但是你不能拿着工价的钱来处理这件事情这个是不行的，
这个事情其实后续的拉扯还是比较多，
但目前解释到今天就是这个样子，
我们之后也可以持续的关注，
今天节目当中最后的一件事就是跟这个婚姻登记连有关，
这个事情说上去有点小荒谬，
我觉得为什么把它选出来，
首先我们来看一个数据好不好，
我特地查了一下，
咱们26年上半年国内的这个婚姻登记，
结婚登记是327.5万对，
同比是减少了26.4万对，
减少了7.5%的，
那原因其实大家都知道现在结婚少的原因主要是这个婚礼人口减少嘛，
对吧,
然后出婚年龄推迟就是现在结婚的年龄越来越往后推，
再加上一个大家对于结婚更加谨慎等等原因，
然后上半年离婚多少对呢，
离婚138.3万对，
其实基本上已经占到了结婚，
就是基本上是40%了吧，
我觉得不到一半，
然后比去年同期又多了5.2万对，
处于历史高位，
结得少离得多，
对好,
那么在这样的一个背景之下，
但是现在我们会看到很多的新闻，
在2026年8月左右开始，
像医院、银行网点、地铁站，
甚至音乐节，
这些场所都开设了婚姻登记点，
这些事情出来之后，
在这个媒体上就会引发很多的一些讨论，
灯顶一些热搜，
首先第一个，
我们来举几个例子，
首先第一个在安徽合肥的幸福坝地铁站，
设立了婚姻登记点，
是全国首个地铁站里面的婚姻登记点，
对,
然后呢，
就是他那边还配了什么打卡墙，
自助拍照，
然后截止到26年7月29号累计已经有，
还真有蛮多的，
6291对新人，
在这里办理了结婚登记，
祝福,
好,
那后面就是在天津，
天津设立了全国首个，
在银行网点的婚姻登记点，
我觉得这个，
这个,
手加什么，
这个蛮离谱的，
手电,
然后26年的8月6号接牌启用，
但是他是每周只有周三和周四上午开放的，
要约约的，
他这里不办理离婚和补证业务，
对，只能结，
他当时说的好像就是说，
刚好结婚之后可以为新婚家庭提供理财咨询，
或者是，
对,
所以这样子就是把他设立到银行里面，
你懂吗？
好,
然后后面，
拓展业务来了，
对,
音乐节这个就是在新疆务卢木齐草莓音乐节，
设立了一个临时的婚姻登记点，
对,
在25年的7月13号，
嗯,
然后呢，
只要新人写在身份证，
登记照片就可以到现场办理，
嗯,
然后就是这个音乐节结束之后，
就这个点也结束了，
撤销了，
这个临时的，
对,
还有像山东滋博的这个富佑宝剑院，
嗯,
设立了婚姻登记点，
啊,
这个我觉得还相对好理解一点，
吧,
对,
就是把婚姻登记和婚前的医学检查，
包括病前的咨询，
夜酸发放就是变成一个一战士服务，
对,
因为,
既然如果大家已经到那边去做婚前检查，
那大概率其实就是准备要结婚了嘛，
我还在想啊，
有没有可能是，
比方说，
两个人不幸不，
就是意外怀孕，
然后想要去富舅宝剑院去咨询，
然后这个时候给你提供一个幸福的启程点，
你们也可以考虑在这个地方结婚，
你知道吧，
很难平啊，
啊,
另外一个就是咱们长沙的，
长沙橘子粥，
啊,
这个之前也上过热搜，
对,
就每天预约30对，
提前三天预约啊，
就是它的这个能够承载的量，
周末可正常办理，
但是湖南首个，
又是首个啊，
首个,
5A级景区结婚登记服务阵地，
然后在5月22号正式启用的，
当这个新闻出来的时候，
我们还吐槽过，
就是因为橘子粥啊，
大家去过的就知道，
首先很难开车，
你要坐地铁去，
完了以后呢，
你上了橘子粥以后，
你要过安检，
过完安检以后，
你要坐小火车，
就是你要在那登革机，
其实很麻烦，
当然了，
就是那个地方意义非凡，
然后它这个事情其实，
大家看到陆续的出来，
它是有政策背景的，
它25年的5月10号，
新修订的婚姻登记条例，
甚至实施，
然后婚姻登记呢，
实现全国通办，
内地居民可在任意，
具备全线的婚姻登记机关，
办理结婚登记，
啊不会受户籍地的限制，
因为之前的话，
是要到你的户籍地的，
那个地方去办，
就南方或者女方，
因为我是结婚的，
我知道，
我知道你结婚婚，
其中一方的这个，
这个户籍所在地，
比如说是雨花区的，
那就到雨花区啊，
或者怎么样，
那这个政策呢，
就为各地拓展多元化的婚姻登记场景，
提供了政策的基础，
然后民政部的数据显示，
条例实施之后，
全国通办婚姻登记累计办理的79.8万对，
就是说还是给大家提供了便利的，
该说不说啊，
然后各地呢，
也陆续的探索了，
像我们刚才说的这个婚姻登记加文旅，
婚姻登记加医疗，
婚姻登记加金融的服务新闻，
我说了嘛，拓展业务来的嘛，
这个新闻一直说的我都想笑啊，
就是我觉得你，
因为跟大家解释一下啊，
不是说，
这些地方可以结婚，
是民政局在那儿设了一个点，
你可以在那儿登记办理，
它确实能够便利，
就比方说我家离这个银行近一点，
离那个民政局远一些，
但是它永远无法提高结婚率，
就是因为我们要思考一个问题，
大家不结婚，
难道是因为结婚办手续不方便吗？
当然不是啊，
大家想结婚的话，
你这个手续哪怕再复杂，
大家也得去办的，
也会结婚，
对不对？
所以我们要讨论几个点，
首先第一个，
它这个初中是希望场景更加的多元，
就避免大家为了结婚就来回跑，
像我刚才说的，
你还要回到户籍所在机，
那很多人可能在外地工作，
他还得回去一趟，
这个我觉得是OK的，
对不对？
好,
那第二个呢就是，
降低领证的物理门槛，
只要一个，
现在好像就只要身份证了嘛，
以前还户口本啊，
对吧?
等等了，
但是我觉得这个根源就在我们刚才讨论的，
结婚低的根源并不在于说不方便，
也不在于说什么之类的，
对吧?
你有住房压力，
有就是御儿成本，
有就业，
就大家现在现在工作的压力等等的，
它不是你把这个东西变得方便了，
就能够解决的，
对啊,
你甚至说你今天告诉我说，
你在手机上就可以结婚，
我也不解，
你在手机小程序上，
你就可以两个人登记结婚，
也不会带来很多的，
就是人就是会去结婚，
而且还有一个问题就是，
结婚这么容易了，
是一件好事吗？
不是,
尤其是在很多你像景区，
像什么音乐节这种，
就是大家本来就很容易上头的地方，
脑子一热就结婚了，
但是你接下来面临的是很多现实的问题啊，
好,
那这个时候你离婚，
又反而变得复杂了，
要三十天冷静期，
也我也是办理过离婚的，
并且说中间有一方不愿意离了，
就又重新来，
我也是办理过离婚的，
就是他这个流程就是你得跑两趟，
因为你离婚你又得去民政局，
好烦,
你懂吧，
结婚我可以在任意的一个地方结，
或者以后说不定真的，
就是在手机上小程序就能办结婚了，
但是我离婚我得跑到那个地方的那个民政局去，
然后我要先填一个表，
然后对方还要跟我调解嘞，
他还把你领了一个房间问，
你们为什么要结婚，
要离婚啊，
然后他会想办法就是说，
去问你有没有不离的可能，
对,
你懂吗，
因为我是经历过整个过程的，
但是当时我跟，
就是我前任去那边离婚的时候，
他我们就说，
我们两个人就对我们两个就很细细哈哈的，
然后那个人说，
第一次看到两个人离婚，
这么开心圣欢，
我说对啊，
我说我们就是和平分手啊，
这是像朋友一样嘛，
然后就离婚了，
就这个行为是很少，
大多数人去了之后都要调解，
怎么原因，
哎呀能不能够多考虑一下什么的，
反正跟你说一通，
OK你一定要离，
这个时候签一个表，
表上就会有一个时间，
三十天之后，
再来一趟，
再去一趟，
也就相对于你为了离婚，
你要跑到那边两趟，
这个门槛又变高了，
但是我觉得，
有没有一种可能，
反而更需要冷静的是结婚这些事情，
对吧,
就是现在变成结婚是一个上头就能够做的事情，
但是,
最应该冷静的反而是结婚，
你反而是应该要想清楚吧，
就这个事情很荒谬的点在这儿，
就是不能只在乎结婚率，
而不在乎离婚率，
对，就是为什么我们一直在讲这个新闻，
是一直在笑一直在笑，
可能很多听众说你们有什么好笑的，
我们其实并不是说结婚或者什么的，
就是我们尊重祝福每一个，
真的因为，
爱情走进婚姻的，
你像瑞秋对吧，
我们的好朋友，
他也马上要结婚了，
真的是真心祝福，
只是觉得说这个事情吧，
就是搞得有点荒谬，
你知道吧，
真的哪一天你信不信，
就是手机上能够登记结婚，
人类识别一下就能够，
就两个人，
所以就是，
还是要思考为什么当下人不愿意结婚，
他不是因为不方便啊，
对不对，
但是我觉得呀，
明面的时候大家都知道为什么当下年，
其实不想结婚，
各种各样的理由，
他只是无力改变或者不愿意承认，
我那天还看到说，
说生一个孩子每个月是每年是给多少，
三千还是给多少，
还是一次性的那种，
就是我差的是那三千吗，
我差的不是啊，
对，那是一个生命，
对，所以大家的考量越多，
我觉得反而大家对于这个事情越谨慎，
顺便大家越成熟，
这是好事儿，
好吧，今天的内容真的讲的很多了啊，
各位应该满意了啊，
是，也希望大家喜欢我们今天这期节目的内容，
我是17,
我是小坛，
我们下期节目再见，
拜拜!